entracte des bahamas alors madame
hussein obama savait que ces prix 1 avec
un homme qui revient du hellfest c'est
eh bien oui c'est très bien rires
nouvelle très très belle coupe et avec
excuse moi tu es la comédienne du manoir
cinéma depuis la semaine dernière la
mort sort aujourd'hui on fait cette
vidéo
un projet qui sort aujourd'hui on va
jouer un jeu tout c'était way déjà ça
s'appelle ta mère en slip c'est bien le
préciser donc choisissez une paire de
lunettes et autres volailles à
démissionner quand même il ya vraiment
du budget il va falloir deviner du coup
le personnage et détails qu'on a sur les
lunettes
et voilà
[Musique]
alors voyons pas de la droite va ce cas
je sais pas ce qui est écrit sur ma tête
mais sur une natte bucca j'aime beaucoup
déjà alors maintenant comment on procède
chypre et on a 30 secondes chaque heure
pour poser le plus de questions de qui
on est et il faut répondre et vous devez
répondre par oui ou par non là tu me
commande elle commence est-ce que je
suis un homme ou une femme femme
chanteuse
oui oui je suis réel j'existe oui
française non américaines non non
derrière moi j'ai la céline dion céline
dion oui oui je suis bien que j'ai pas
bien non pas à très bien la nuit je n'en
aurais je suis en train de vomir non
gaza non c'est fini
ah [ __ ] t'as trouvé déjà passé la
moitié j'ai en deuil un deuil qui valide
et heures à bien jouer jusqu'au 22
julien devrait choisir attention c'est
parti
six jeunes hommes oui ce que je suis un
artiste
non non ce que je suis un politicien oui
mais à ce que je suis un petit gars
sympa je ponce tranquille est ce que je
sais des droits non c'est ce que je suis
exerce encore c'est un homme non non on
femmes
oui oui un animal non excellent je suis
chanteuse
oui au siège de moi je suis blanche
c'est fini c'est fini
merci à tous pour votre soutien c'est
parti je suis un homme non une femme oui
oui je mets enquête
oui je suis jolie oui je chante une
chanson i will kate perry
non non je suis ça fait 10 ans bloqué et
mais vous savez quoi je suis le seul à
avoir déjà joué je suis le plus nul
c'est parti est ce que je regarde à vue
non non tu mènes menotté nom en tête lag
non c'est compliqué je suis tombé je me
suis blessé non c'est dans un dans un
espace fermé
oui j'ai perdu mes clés très bonne
question
mer forte
c'est parti ok politiciens de gauche
ouais on sait pas comment c'est ça ouais
inconnue il a connu un très très bon
dirigeant très connu mais bon encore
tout juste des chiraquiens
non jacques chirac y aura des heureux
je connais la chanteuse ou pas oui elle
a vendu beaucoup d'albums
oui c'est katy perry non non non les
françaises ont fait un nom à nombre de
lettres et en lettres il est pas loin
yannick noah
mais si une femme jusqu'à la glace mais
je vais jamais trouvé je suis une
chanteuse
ouais je suis très joli mais avec je
suis bien ici je suis couleur blanche
ouais j'suis pas katy perry je suis
américaine je suis taylor swift croyait
ces jeux je vais pas bien non
coderre bien suis bourré oui je suis tes
la rue de bourg et oui je suis très
satisfait d'avoir gagné parce que les
partis que j'ai fait avant je perdais
tout le temps alors là tout est prêt si
rien n'est fait dans un endroit c'est
parti
je suis en faire une toilette non non
dans une boîte de nuit non je suis dans
des câbles mais les clés pour aller
faire tes papiers des valeurs on n'est
pas loin donc pas commissariat safran
est pas loin est pas loin du tout j'ai
oublié les indices je sais que c'est
françois prouver quelque chose et
françois qui fait quelque chose
franchement qui est dans un film porno
non ce que c'est un moment droit qui
on n'a pas de mandat les basses il faut
y aller chanteuse trois lettres ses
partisans je fais l'alphabet sinon alors
est-ce que ça commence pas à non par bbc
j'y vais je voudrais ici
oui toujours non mais enfin
oui mais à mesa je pensais qu'il y avait
eu un exemple tout paris sait mardi à la
poste un endroit administratif à nice tu
rates tu veux
ouais ouais là tu t'es un truc là voilà
je vais attendre comme ça que sa vie
n'est pas terminée la garde à vue en
garde à vue non je suis un indice sur ma
carte
d'accord je suis en cure de désintox oui
[Applaudissements]
veut aller aux caisses à un état non
c'est une action non je suis dans un
endroit
oui c'est pas très cool non c'est pas
très cool ça vous ne savez pas très
drôle du tout c'est à paris non mais en
france non c'est aux us c'est sur la
planète
oui c'est irréel oui ok sûr je suis
perdu je sais pas mais bien sûr si des
fichiers
je sais pas a b c d e f g h i j k l n o
m
après l eau oui a b c d e f g h et l et
m oui elles mêmes au we hope au poste on
y ajoute la préfecture et la poste les
nuls laissez moi je convie aussi elle
aussi webradios sais pas si je suis
françois hollande
ok allez c'est parti
ok donc c'est un lieu réel c'est grand
c'est grand c'est un pays à y laisser un
pea
c'est un pays boos touristiques ont tout
autant mais c'est quoi ces housses et
vers les us nov
c'est vers l'europe et l'australie
[ __ ] mais c'est pas des continents
l'afrique approche et la menteuse et
l'enrichissent aimions pôle emploi alors
maintenant tu es all-in sur toi moi je
suis une merde à nos questions sur le
prix vous y êtes déjà allé calais est ce
qu'un ami à vous y est déjà allé
insolent états unis afrique du sud et
amérique du sud amérique du nord en
antarctique oublie vrai moi quand il a
dit oui à bray dunes on attend date est
tué je suis à un coup des meneurs zsa
zsa entourés des leurs c'est stressant
ce jeu j'arrête j'arrête je vous laisse
faire la deuxième game sur moi je suis
stressée au min et une 12e gala on fait
nos amis où j'ai déjà joué plusieurs
fois je n'y vois un peu élevé du coup il
me trouve des cartes custom qu'ils
inventent et ça c'est aussi les lunettes
de lucas c'est bon c'est bon
[Musique]
jules m est-ce que je vais galérer de ou
fat boy non non non non c'est jouable
ok on est petit par holmes guy youtuber
non chanteur français oui booba non
la fouine non c'est un groupe dense tout
seul tout seul tout seul mais il a été
dans un groupe aulas n'est que non et
c'est fini tu le feras oui on y va ôter
ce chanteur ménard musiciens un
politicien non non animateur non non
sportif non mais pas du tout là vraiment
mal à l'opposé il opposait deux sportifs
youtuber objectivement je suis un homme
j'ai un acteur non je suis un chanteur
c'est un politicien je suis youtuber non
je suis réel non non je suis issue d'une
d'un animé ouais ben non d'un dessin
animé d'un dessin animé japonais non
d'un dessin animé belge d'un dessin
animé africains n'ont créé par dams je
suis un homme
oui oui je passe à la télé oui les gens
aiment bien ça des projets de merde moi
ça va je suis dans la musique
oui le chanteur oui français oui et
c'est trop tard ça c'est parti à
l'incroyable cette partie d'un groupe
s'est laissé le suspense réalisateur oui
oui l'acteur âgé pas des acteurs non
mince pêcheur boulanger donc je viens
d'un dessin animé
oui alors on peut bien le dessin animé
il est français mais non il est
américain
oui un dessin animé américain les pères
à des saluts et américains futurama nos
gars film
je suis black m me déjà bien tu attends
mais réfléchi et je suis black m oui je
suis enfermée dans un lieu je suis dans
un pays dans un endroit
ces drames ont droit à un repas de
famille nombreux mois
anniversaire doc recteur français wave
et google chine wen août que vous aimez
bien tout le monde aime on n'adore pas
sportif du tout sportif ou norman
thavaud je vais tâter novateur dont
beaucoup plus déterminés c'est parti ok
donc des scènes américaines american dad
non [ __ ] mais c'est pas possible at on
assisté qu'à les simpson a laissé les
simpson les simpson je suis dans un
groupe
oh je suis vieux mais la laitue l'a été
et bah je suis un pote de ma came as je
suis maître gims je suis d'abord aux
attentes par bombay une activité oui moi
quelque chose à je fais quelque chose
quelque chose il ya des changes mais je
sais au choix ça des portes tu le four
tops ont plus connu de tous les acteurs
français j'ai fait un film cette année
voit tout le temps d'attenté moyen c'est
bonjour même si on n'a rien vu du film
on s'est quand même passé ça soye
tournefeuille bois gilles de tous il
boit depardieu et fait quoi qui picolent
non lieu c'est fini c'est s'est diffusée
en france sur à la télé française
oui sur w9 gcc rien franchement je vois
là aussi je fais une activité collective
je fais souvent cette saison ne tend pas
trop ces derniers temps pas trop dans
une crèche avec mais pas l'eau la fête
des mères fête des pères et fête des
grands mères dans une maison de retraite
la grand mère que tu ailles chine mais
tu es donc black out in any way pardon
les mecs je peux juste vous donner une
petite info j'ai toujours
avec à donner aux jeunes mecs mais non
[ __ ] c'est sauce marque
ouais je suis un ange venu je suis sur
ce parc est alors je suis ok c'est un
endroit et à l'endroit
oui ok c'est bon alors je laisse aux
particuliers ggg trouve l'endroit plus
là on est la plage
non non l'opposé l'opposait à l'opposé
dans un igloo un peu moins à l'opposé à
et tu vas à la montagne voilà ok remake
c'est une zone géographique
non non c'est un endroit caché mois oui
c'est un endroit car dans ma ville oui
oui c'est chiant c'est bien tout est
servi tu te déteste ça tu as déjà été
une fois ou deux mois ouais oui je met
en ligne une vidéo non je tourne une
vidéo je suis très impatient de produit
chez maître gims il ya alors qui va
finir dernier une deuxième fois à grâce
à ça j'ai eu entre vous cap donc je suis
en après ski alors ça c'est un lieu
c'est ça se passe que à la montagne
c'est ma seule chance de trouver fête
s'adresse à la science de trouver donc
je suis allé deux fois et ce qu'il
faudrait que j'y aille là une nouvelle
fois franchement non c'est bien bien
est-ce que cat man a raison d'y aller
oui est ce que c'est parce qu'il est
gros week hartmann à la salle oui aïe
aïe aïe
jeanne par dieu sur un télésiège des
amis c'était fun
c'était la fin de cette vidéo sur ta
mère ans mais ce coup dur que si je vous
dis très clairement c'est terminé
c'était pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
de jeu le fou donné à tous de cyprien
lui il débute en plus il n'était pas
fier parce qu'on produit alors ça rendra
cette blague encore plus drôle et puis
accrue dans une prochaine vidéo merci à
le passer merci je suis tout tactile je
suis très attendu stable
[Musique]